le tourisme régional c'est bien sûr la
loire les châteaux et les produits du
terroir tous les week-end de pentecôte
gilles cholin lance sa campagne estivale
grâce à l'opération
pique nique chez le vigneron c'est les
alsaciens qui ont initié ce pique nique
des vignerons indépendants cei c'est
quelque chose que j'ai trouvé j'ai
toujours trouvé fabuleux le tourisme on
utilise ça pour pour communiquer c'est
un vecteur pour nouer et on trouve ça
passionnant encore une fois ça fait
partie du métier de vigneron que de que
de partager aussi c'est cultiver la
vigne c'est faire sauveur mais c'est
également partager son savoir partager
son métier sa mesure la quantité de
sucre mais ça le tran huy en alcool
potentiel à quelques centaines de mètres
cédric chaulées parle technique avec le
premier groupe de la journée
le no tourisme est un axe majeur du
développement de son exploitation
il a même créé son petit musée de la
vigne pour retenir les visiteurs chez
lui c'est un produit touristique complet
qui est proposée le n'autorise c'est un
petit peu plus que que la visite de la
cave on propose vraiment une prestation
supplémentaire
on leur fait découvrir le terroir donc
les sols les vignes les cépages
qu'est-ce qu'on utilise pour faire nos
vins nos assemblages et c est à chaque
fois que l'on a un à l'occasion alors
c'est plus ou moins long des fois mais
une petite visite de quelques heures
aujourd'hui ça dure deux heures mais on
peut faire des visites à d'un quart
d'heure vingt minutes voilà ça peut être
des fois un petit peu plus rapide
évidemment tout cela est bon pour le
commerce du vin dans les exploitations
qui joue pleinement cette carte
le quart du chiffre d'affaires est
constitué par les retombées de
l'oenotourisme